all right hot breath averse welcome back
to hot breath podcast the show where you
learn comedy from the pros you are
watching comedians on skype talking
comedy where we ask your favorite
questions to your favorite comedians if
you're watching on YouTube all of these
questions are being asked live in our
Facebook group so go into the
description and click join the Facebook
group so you can get involved in Future
q and A's
but today's guest he embodies the spirit
of hot breath that self-made independent
hustle please bring a warm welcome for
the one and only Ted Alexandro ladies
and gentlemen give it up for Ted yeah
thank you everyone I'll be I'm gonna be
reading The Very Hungry Caterpillar to
you that's basically what I've been
doing the last few months so we'll just
keep it we'll keep it in that vein well
yeah we appreciate you taking time out
of your family to actually sit here and
share some comedy wisdom with us today
oh my pleasure my pleasure thank you for
having me Joel so I've been I've
personally been a huge fan and know
several of our listeners have as people
are already commenting with their
questions but listeners go ahead and get
into your questions go ahead start
posting them and I'm gonna selfishly ask
a few here oh and some Wayne already
said enjoyed stay at home every day I
get a scare too lol Thank You Wayne yeah
gotta stay strong man find a way through
it and that that's a that's a great
place to start with this with a stay at
home comedian your newest special you
just released based off Instagram live
videos could you
I tried researching I always research my
guests and I tried researching into the
origin story of this but I haven't found
it so would you be able to share that
with us here sure thing yeah
so basically once the pandemic hit and
once the quarantine specifically hit you
know comedy clubs were shut down I had
been touring with Jim Gaffigan and we
were actually just on
our way to Mexico we were about I think
you know a few days away from doing a
week in Mexico so all of that was
canceled we were supposed to be at Radio
City in in New York that was canceled so
all of a sudden you know just yeah just
a minor gig you know nothing big apart
so all of a sudden I'm looking at an
empty slate so like a lot of comedians I
kind of turned to alternate platforms so
I have a podcast so I started doing two
podcasts a week on my podcast is called
a little bit me and I also started live
streaming on Instagram live it just kind
of seemed like a natural fit like since
I wasn't able to get up on stages and
because all this weird stuff was going
on I felt like you know let me try to
process this in real-time and let me
also with Instagram live much like
Facebook you're able to see comments in
real time so I kind of felt like it's a
good interactive thing as well so then
over the course of a couple weeks I just
thought to myself you know if I take the
best moments of these weeks of you know
live streams a lot of them were close to
an hour in length you know just kind of
take the highlights and string them
together this could be something worth
putting out and then the more I thought
about it it would be kind of funny
almost like tongue-in-cheek to refer to
it as a comedy special even though it
was shot in quarantine in my apartment
so it's like almost like the anti
special really because it's as small and
as intimate as can be and you've always
been like anti the trend you know I mean
you are a founding member of the New
York comedians coalition that helped New
York comedians get paid more you've also
been involved in Occupy Wall Street but
even way back in the dizzay before it
was cool to release your own special you
were already releasing your own specials
with I did it me did Creek in the cave
in front of like 30 people and then
senior class of Earth as well you went
through all things comedy but it was
still seemingly independent that's right
it I'm I did that with mine I just
released my own comedy special
independently and I have to accredit you
paving the path for us comics to show oh
this is possible and do you were you
intentional about that or what is it
about you seeing a trend and then trying
to find the contrary of that have you
found that to be kind of a useful way to
pursue comedy yeah well first off
congratulations to you on putting out
your special and your album yeah I kind
of feel like that's the most organic way
of creating and releasing stuff you know
the other way is really what is
inorganic where you give up what you've
created - whether it's Comedy Central or
Netflix really the only reason to do
that well there's a couple one is money
obviously because you're gonna get a
bigger payday from those kind of
corporate entities than you will on your
own the other is exposure eyeballs you
know but also you're giving up ownership
so this so there is something you know I
guess like with any business transaction
there's pros and cons and a
give-and-take so for me all of my
specials have been independently
produced my first one was as much as you
want now what was interesting about that
was I had done two half-hour specials
for Comedy Central in the late 90s early
2000s so then I shot my special after
that but I did it myself so I had I had
the exposure of the half hour specials
already but I kind of felt like and to
this day I still feel unless they're
throwing a lot of money at you which
isn't the case for a lot of comedians
but unless they're throwing a lot of
money at you to me there isn't a whole
lot to think about you know because I
don't want to give up ownership of this
thing that I've crafted over years and
also with with your streaming income now
if you know Sirius XM streams your
comedy or Spotify Pandora all these
streaming services you want to get two
checks from both the artist and the
rights owner
and if you give up your special you
surrender the rights ownership so then
Netflix or Comedy Central or whoever it
is will be the rights owner so there's
you know there's business things to
consider yes and I apologize for missing
as much as you want I
oh that's okay yeah long time ago yeah I
always I mean I always do thorough
research and I'm kind of embarrassed
that I missed that no not at all so when
it comes to releasing your own special
independently what did you find to be
like the biggest Pro as opposed to
trying to sell it to a network I mean
what short-term I guess you get paid
upfront by the network so you get that
initial payment but it seems like they
get a lot more of the back end but with
you how have you been able to monetize
creating this high valued free content
yeah so even like with my my Comedy
Central specials I think they paid like
maybe 25,000 or 30,000 dollars which
after taxes is you know between half and
two-thirds of that you know so it's not
you're not getting $30,000 that you're
getting whatever it winds up being I
don't opens 18 19,000 Wow so you know
that is a lot of money of course for
comedian you're starting out you know
you you're barely making anything you
know you're doing a lot of free gigs
you're doing a lot of bar gigs so that
those first pay days of course are very
exciting but yeah the the pros are for
me again like when you enter a creative
field presumably you're doing it because
you have ideas and you have ideas about
not only your jokes and your material
and the way you present it but you have
ideas about how you want things to look
so for example my last special senior
class of Earth the one before stayed
home comedian senior class of Earth I
shot at the comedy sellers second room
the village underground they have three
clubs
the cellar of courses is the main one on
mcdu
Street and then around the corner they
have two other clubs the village
underground which is a little bigger and
also the fat black pussycat which is
kind of a loungy small club but the
seller owns all three of them so I shot
senior class of earth at the village
underground which seats about 200 people
but to your question I had ideas about
like how I wanted it to look you know
like when you do a special for Comedy
Central or Netflix or whoever a lot of
those decisions are taken out of your
hands how you want it to look the the
staging the lighting so for senior class
of Earth I worked with my director who
I've done a lot of things with two of my
specials three now including
stay-at-home comedian and we designed
like we wanted it to kind of be smoky
kind of like an intimate Club feel with
kind of red lighting and and you know
different types of different types of
looks so I don't think if I had done it
with Comedy Central I would have had the
autonomy that I did doing it myself so
basically the answer to your question is
it gives you as the artist more control
you know which i think is a good thing
it's good to think about how do I want
this to look how do I want it to sound
you know to take more ownership over
your your product it have in terms of
getting a return on that investment have
you seen I mean is it just growing a
larger fan base that then listen to your
podcast more incomes and see you live
you know how are you able to correlate
that return yeah that's that's a good
question so it's not like an initial
paycheck like you would get from Comedy
Central or from Netflix so you know I
mean I've had friends who have sold
their special to Netflix and don't get
me wrong I explored I explored that
possibility I've reached out to Netflix
I know some people there but they passed
on senior class of Earth so that was
disappointing because at least I wanted
to kind of explore it and see you know
if I could if like you know I've had
comedian a lot of comedian friends who
have specials on Netflix and you know in
a lot of cases there
you're looking at maybe a quarter of a
million dollars or you know 300,000 and
up I mean of course like the big names
with your Seinfeld or if you're
Chappelle you know then we're talking
crazy numbers 10 million 20 million
whatever whatever it is for a special
but I'm talking like working comedians
peers of mine that I've come up with you
know it's usually quarter of a million
three hundred thousand in that ballpark
so I think at this point you know
especially now having a family I'd be
willing to listen to those numbers to
surrender the ownership you know at
least for maybe one special or something
you know you so you have to you have to
weigh all these things so yeah for me at
this point like it is good that I have
the ownership of it I did it with all
things comedy as you said which is a
company that's owned by Bill burr al
Madrigal so it's comedian owned which
kind of resonated with me so they gave
me a check that covered a lot of the
costs of the production because I went
out of pocket to shoot it and to pay the
director the production team all of that
so I kind of recoup with with that and I
also worked with 800 pound gorilla
Records for the audio side of things so
I kind of recoup my money upfront and
now with the streaming and with all of
that now now I'm kind of been in the
clear and making profits going forward
so it was kind of a thing of like let me
at least not lose money and now I'm now
I'm seeing a profit you know as things
go forward yeah we had mark Normand on
here and he was talking about Netflix
was I mean he may have been joking it's
it's tough to tell with him but he was
pretty much like whatever it's like
Netflix told me you know we have enough
white honkies you gotta have you either
have to come in with a big following
already or come in with like an angle or
a stick type deal at this point yeah
yeah I mean that is kind of the
landscape now that it's either big stars
household names or you know
a lot of these corporate entities are
rightfully trying to diversify so women
people of color you know they're they're
using the people that in a lot of cases
they've ignored in the past so you know
for me I don't feel like you know like
don't cry any tears for me like oh the
white guys are having a hard time yeah I
don't see it that way like you know I
had two Comedy Central Presents specials
and I had plenty of late-night sets on
Letterman and all these other things so
you know it's the landscape has changed
in that regard but there's plenty of
other outlets so yeah you just have to
be more creative in your thinking
beautiful alright let's let's get into
some questions here as we jump in with a
number one chase Bannen
he says you're described as a Comics
comic how do you feel about that and
what is your interpretation of that
phrase also do you have a favorite
comedian that you described as a Comics
comic thanks for the question chase yeah
I take that as a compliment you know
amongst comedians that is high praise
you know when you're known as a Comics
comic because I think what it means is
that you make comedians laugh - because
comedians we can get a little bit jaded
you know we can kind of we see so much
comedy that at times you know maybe
we're a little bit harder to get to
laugh so yeah to me I think it just
maybe says that my peers respect me and
that that has always meant a lot to me
so that's that's a good thing and when I
think of a Comics comic the immediate
person that comes to mind is Dave Attell
he's the guy like coming up through New
York City that all of the comedian's
would stand in the back of the room and
watch you know because as I said we see
so many so many comedians we see so much
comedy we respect everybody but when
when you have comedians lining up in the
back of the room and stopping to watch
you that's high praise so Dave Attell
really the pinnacle of a Comics comic in
my mind it's a fine line in terms of
your comics comic you get the respect of
your peers that's awesome but your peers
aren't going to pay the bills you know
and it's kind of a tough it's a tough
balancing act there I mean what is your
opinion on that
well that's a good point I think that's
part of it too
because at times when they say a Comics
comic they mean that the audience
doesn't get them like maybe somebody
like Larry David back in the day before
he started writing with Seinfeld I hurt
you know I never saw him he was a little
bit before my time as a stand-up but I
heard he was pretty adversarial and
would kind of like go with the crowd and
do these crazy things and kind of maybe
walk offstage you know but the the
comics were always cracking up so that's
a different type of comics comic I don't
really see myself in that category like
I I try to make the crowd laugh and I
don't really have an antagonistic
relationship with the audience so I you
know my approach is of course always to
make the audience laugh and for people
to have a good time but yeah the fact
that comedians also respect me is
important to me but yeah I know what
you're saying like some at times there
are people that the business doesn't
know what to do with because they're too
bizarre or you know comedians love them
but maybe the crowd doesn't get them or
they're too avant-garde yeah but I've
you know fortunately for me I've been
able to make a living and it hasn't
really affected you know like like I
said mom I see my first job is to make
people laugh you know boom great yeah
great point there so the next one
actually ties into entertaining the
audience as opposed to comedians and
this comes from MIT Wolfe he says that
when Nate bargatze was on here he talked
about how comics need to get back to
murdering and he was like he was like
murder he would like say it like from
his soul he was so intent about murder
on stage but so he says when was the
first time you murdered and what made
the difference thank you for the
question
I can't really remember the first time I
murdered but I did feel comfortable on
stage pretty early on because I had done
a lot of acting in high school in
college so being on stage was not
foreign to me at all but it did take a
little time to kind of get my footing in
terms of stand-up but I do remember like
killing maybe in the first you know few
years where I kind of felt like oh you
know I think I'm on to something here
and I have a style and yeah I mean
that's it's a great feeling but you know
I'm sure Nate probably alluded to this
that there's different types of
murdering or killing like this if you're
doing it like in a way that feels cheap
to you and as a young comic that that
can be the danger if you have something
that kills but maybe it's um you know
maybe it's cheapen in whatever way you
know and that's that's kind of a little
bit of a trap that young comedians tend
to fall into because when it when as he
said you know when you kill it feels it
feels so good but you know it has to
square with your integrity too you know
and that varies from person to person so
you'll know if you're killing with a
cheap laugh or something that doesn't
really square with your integrity versus
if you kill with something that you know
is it's coming from your voice and as
authentic that's that's the best feeling
because then you don't have any qualms
about it that is something that is my
favorite part about your comedy even up
beyond the writing which there there's a
question about thank goodness because
I'd definitely get into your writing but
you're you refer to it a second ago as
like your comfort on stage and even
beyond that like your timing and I know
you have like a jazz background like you
play jazz piano and all that and it's
like your timing you're in
zero rush like your movement seemed to
be just not choreographed but very
methodical like how were you able to
because young comics especially it's
that nervous energy I gotta get these
words out before everyone hates me but
like how were you and what was that
process of massaging out that anxiety
and really just being like oh I have all
the time in the world up here mmm
yeah well that's a good point you know I
think the trap is to feel rushed and the
trap is to feel like there can't be any
silence there can't be any dead air and
I I used to fall into that trap too of
you know thinking that I had to speak
very quickly and be animated and you
know my energy had to be like through
the roof you know and as you do stand-up
for 10 years 20 years you figure things
out about yourself and about your style
hopefully you're always learning you're
always dissecting your own craft and the
way you approach it but but I kind of
found over the years that you know maybe
that was a little bit of a crutch you
know like to to not give the audience
any space and again it depends
stylistically on how you work for some
people you know it's like a machine gun
it's like a sledge hammer they go go go
and and I love it if you know it's all
about authenticity
if that's who you are and that's the way
you work then I love it you know but if
it's forced and you're doing it out of
fear you know I would just encourage
people to explore like what exactly are
you afraid of for me
I over time found that you could find
laughs or maybe even extra little
moments would pop up if I allowed for a
silence you know because the crowd
really reads you if you are like you
said if you're at peace and unrushed and
comfortable then they're gonna go with
you
you know there
always kind of they're assessing are you
comfortable up there they're assessing
like what's this person about and if
they sense fear or if they sense that
you are you know just unsure then the
room will register that but if you're
really planted and firm then I think
they kind of lean in and they want to
know like where you're going and
different moments can happen in those
silences - well maybe a look right like
something physical like a gesture well
you know a lot of things can happen in
the silences you know so that's
something I've learned over time yeah
one of my favorite quotes we've had and
doing these q naze with Alonzo Bodden
said that if you're afraid to say it
they're afraid to hear it that's like
that's yeah it's a game-changer yeah I
mean I would piggyback on that and say
like sometimes you're afraid to say
things but you know you have to you know
like so sometimes if I'm doing a joke
that maybe is like social commentary or
something political like I'm a little
not scared
I wouldn't say scared is the right word
but I I'm just concerned about making
sure that it lands the way that I intend
you know so I I think sometimes a little
bit and I'm sure Alonzo you know he he
didn't mean it you know I'm sure he's
aware of this - he and I are great
friends but what I'm saying is at times
when you're afraid to say something or
that you're a little like that helps you
grow like it helps you grow when you
know cuz there's a there's different
types of labs there's an easy laughs
where you're just talking about your
family or your girlfriend boyfriend
whatever your significant other and then
there's a laugh where you're kind of
stating an opinion or maybes commenting
on society so there's different types of
colors within the course of your act so
so those types of things might require a
little bit more you know you have to be
a little more resolute in I'm gonna
plant my feet and I'm gonna I'm gonna
say this and this is
perfectly tying into Steven Rogers next
question where he says how do you come
back to a bit you believed in but
couldn't get to work
that's a good question Steven there's a
lot of bits like that you know that
there's bits over the years where you
think there's something there and you
love it you love the idea you love the
joke ultimately you have to listen to
the crowd though if it's dying night
after night for months on end you know
maybe it's time to put it on the shelf
it doesn't mean that don't do it forever
because I've had jokes that I came back
to a year later five years later and you
just rework it so if you really believe
in something don't retire it but maybe
just keep working on it put it on the
Shelf give it a little time rework it in
your notebook you know sometimes it's a
process if it's like I said if it's if
there's a degree of difficulty with the
joke you know like I said if I if it's
about you know relationships or if it's
about like taking a [ __ ] or whatever you
know like people are gonna just laugh
because whatever it's it's just they
know you're joking but if it has a
higher degree of difficulty then that
might take some time it might take years
you know so to answer your question
Steven if you feel strongly about it
just you know keep trying it keep trying
it but if it never works
then you gotta you got to think like
alright maybe I got to put this on the
shelf for a while so when you talk about
taking it to like the page and you're
like maybe I need to rework it on the
page
Wayne flake asks like what is your
favorite riding technique and maybe make
that plural in terms of like what are
some of your go-to riding techniques to
kind of put your jokes through a
checklist type deal yeah well when I
started my main technique was to write
everyday sit down for two hours and that
was a
lack of time that worked for me it's
it's different for everyone but I would
encourage people to go for two hours
because sometimes in that first hour
nothing really comes you know sometimes
you're sitting there and maybe just a
few sentences or whatever but if you
know I'm in this chair for two hours my
phone is off I'm not looking you know I
and I write with a pen and paper too
mostly because I don't want the
distraction of potentially logging onto
the internet or looking at my Facebook
or whatever else so for me pen and paper
means it's just me I'm in this chair I'm
with my thoughts and I know I'm here for
two hours I don't care what happens I
don't care what distractions come up I'm
just staying and writing and if you do
that for you know five days a week for a
month for two months for six months
really what you're doing is you're
learning your voice you're learning your
process you're spending intimate time
with yourself which is important you
know because when you go up in front of
a crowd you are making a request for
their attention you're asking for their
focus to be on you so what have you done
to earn that have you put in the time
have you put in the hours do you know
what you have to say because if you
don't know what you have to say and you
don't know who you are you know it begs
the question do you really deserve to
ask a room of people to listen now you
know I mean of course you do deserve it
because you're a human being and you're
you're offering your thoughts and your
you're offering you know your creativity
so that has its own merit but I'm
talking about in the grand scheme of
like being a professional and getting
everything yeah I'm not just talking
about an open mic at a coffee shop you
know don't get me wrong I'm not
everybody has the right to get up on
stage that's great but I'm talking about
really sitting with yourself and
discovering who you are
so that takes time and you really have
to give your craft the proper respect
and the property
I'm so over years that developed another
thing that I did was early on study
everybody whether it's people that
you're working with but study the
Great's study Richard Pryor George
Carlin everyone moms Mabley you know
everyone that you can think of Bob
Newhart Steven right on up through
Chappelle you know just study everybody
who really owns their craft you know and
another thing that I would do is when I
had my jokes sometimes I would recite
them in other people's styles I would
say to myself like how would Steven
Wright deliver this joke how would
George Carlin deliver this joke because
what that does is those people have very
distinct styles right Steven Wright is
kind of low-key
deadpan dry Carlin is more high-energy
more physical so sometimes you know like
Sam Kinison whoever it is think of
different styles and you know it's
really just an exercise for you to say
like am I getting everything out of this
joke that I can be that that fits my
style you know as you're figuring out
your style because if you try it in
whoever you know fill in the blank if
you tried in Gary Gulman style or
whoever maybe you'll find one little
moment in the joke that wasn't there
before maybe a pause maybe a facial
gesture maybe something physical
maybe you'll be louder because you tend
to be quiet or vice-versa
so yeah I think exploring different
people's voices when you're starting out
is a good mental kind of exploration and
let's take a step back to this to our
writing because it's very romantic as
comedians I'm gonna sit down and write
everyday and I'm and I feel unfortunate
with this comedy group we're in here at
hot breath that we do a write 10 club
every day where we
show up in right for 10 minutes just to
just to have some sort of daily ritual
some sort of daily habit and social
accountability but two hours how how are
you how are you able to commit to this
what mindset or what habits did you set
in place that like I'm doing this no
matter what well first off I would
commend anyone who's doing the 10
minutes because when you establish those
habits that's a positive you know no
matter how much time it is and like you
said accountability and there's a social
aspect of kind of having you know like a
bit of a binding contract of sorts so
all of that is is good stuff but you
have to really assess like what are your
goals you know if your goal is to be a
professional comedian if you want this
to be your job I would suggest that you
approach it as such you know 10 minutes
is a good start but that's likely not
going to get you to where you want to be
as a professional you know to be a
professional you have to kind of get out
of your comfort zone and I think it's
important to create habits that you'll
look back on with pride and you'll say
wow I remember when I was starting I
worked harder than I thought I could you
know cuz I look back I was teaching I
was going to school I was working at a
supermarket and I was doing the open
mikes five nights a week I was writing
two hours a day so you know when I look
back on that I was like wow I was insane
but I was also doing what I loved and I
was creating habits so that's another
thing to really focus on that you're
creating habits in the early going that
are going to potentially separate you
from other people and you're never going
to regret working harder you know you're
never going to regret putting in an
extra hour you know you you know
especially in the early going because
you're really
establishing habits you know so those
are those who you're almost acquiring
tools for your tool belt so you want
your tool belt to be full you know so
yeah just you know I'm assuming if
you're in this group you're someone that
loves comedy and many of you want to
pursue it professionally so those are
the things that are really going to
separate you is is your approach and
your work habit you're never going to
regret working harder that Oh dropping
dimes over here okay
so let's get a two Gironde cuz this is
yeah this is an important one as well
when it comes to actually the mindset
behind being a professional comedian
there could be a lot of self-doubt and
Juran young asks what self-doubt or
resistance did you feel in the beginning
of your career and how do you deal with
it now thanks to Ron yeah I would say
that you know that's just part of the
the deal especially when you're starting
you feel self-doubt all the time you
wonder like do I belong is this funny
what am i doing yeah you have all sorts
of doubts in the early going so that's
that's part of the deal you know so you
kind of have to overcome that and the
beauty of comedy is it really affords
you the opportunity to figure out who
you are not only on stage but off you
know with it's you really through all of
the time that you're spending writing
all the time on stage all the time with
your fellow comedians you're figuring
out who you are and there are people
that are putting you in check the
audience is putting you in check and
saying like nah that's not working I
don't believe that coming out of your
mouth and that'll be different for
everyone
you know they they'll believe it coming
out of one person's mouth but they won't
believe the same bit coming out of that
person's mouth because it just doesn't
jive with what they're looking at you
know so it's really a process of like
what does the audience believe coming
out of my mouth and what that does over
years is it lets you know who you are it
lets you know what your voice is so yeah
and also your fellow comedians let you
know like you know that's not really
working that like your fellow comedians
will kind of also tell you you know what
what works what doesn't but over the
years those self-doubts start to shed
because you accumulate so much stage
time you you accumulate successful
experiences yeah so you start to really
know who you are and you really you have
a confidence that really becomes
unshakable over time not to say that you
know there are times where you still
don't hit the mark the way you want to
or a night doesn't go the way that you'd
hoped but it doesn't shake your
confidence you just know that okay like
for whatever reason you know you still
have to assess like was that something
that I did was you know was it my
approach that was wrong or you know so
that doesn't end but you don't have the
crisis of confidence like oh I guess I
guess I'm not good I guess I'm not a
comedian you know you know that there's
another show the next night and we'll
wrap up with this one because it's
actually something you just referred to
and that is finding your voice which
every comedian wants to do so Trent Babb
asks what advice do you have for finding
your voice well Trent I would say the
main thing is doing it just you know
again if you relentlessly work you know
in the writing process it has to be the
the thing that's very odd and almost
singular really about stand-up comedy is
that the two components of it couldn't
be more different you're creating
something in solitary kind of you know
in solitude you're alone in a room right
you're alone with your thoughts
the quiet just kind of sitting there and
brainstorming and daydreaming really and
then the execution of it is in a room
full of people and noise and and
sometimes chaos and drinks and and food
and so it's too
very different you know environments in
which the creation takes place and then
the performance takes place but you have
to put time into both the writing is
that time with yourself and knowing this
is how my brain thinks this is how I
create you know the intimacy of knowing
yourself and then also the time onstage
performing those are really the steps of
finding your voice and that takes you
have to also be gentle with yourself I
would encourage you to not be harsh
because a lot of times we can be overly
critical and overly harsh and kind of
shoot ourselves down but really I would
encourage you to lift yourself up if
you're putting in the work then pat
yourself on the back and say you know
like even if it doesn't go great if
you're putting in the work then you know
make sure that you're being kind with
yourself and being gentle with yourself
because what you're doing is not easy
you know so yeah just immerse yourself
in it do the work and then there's gonna
be nights that are difficult there's
gonna be days when you missed the mark
but that's life you know that's part of
being human so yeah I would encourage
people to to being kind to yourselves as
well well we hit the mark with this one
Ted you are a comedy sensei and the hot
breath averse thanks you for your
valuable time in closing is there any of
your favorite comedy advice or anything
you can bestow upon us as we exit this
well Thank You Joel for having me it's a
real pleasure and thank you to everybody
who's watching and submitting questions
yeah I would say you know that it's it's
really a lifestyle choice you know when
when you get into comedy or you get into
the arts so you know it's not something
that is separate it's you can't really
compartmentalize it it's really your
life it's the way you see the world it
starts to become
your social circles you know so really
you know you have to kind of you have to
jump in with with both feet and but it's
very rewarding too because you kind of
start to shed a lot of the insecurities
that that a lot of people have because
you you've worked for something and
you've worked on yourself so there's a
real reward in that process of you know
it's really exploration the whole thing
is is exploration and creativity and
also the act of giving you know your to
show up in front of a roomful of
strangers night after night and give of
yourself is it's a beautiful act you
know of course there's ulterior motives
and you want to you want to do well and
you want to you know kind of move up the
ranks and get on television and all the
other things but I think at its core the
most simple aspect of what it is is the
selfless act of wanting to connect with
people and wanting to bring people
together and have a good time so you
know that's really the root of all of it
I love it people saying thank you Ted
people saying this is great advice why
yes
yeah you've you've really made a big
impact with us here today at hot breath
how can we support you where where could
people go and follow you and listen to
you and all that oh my pleasure thank
you for the kind words
people can find me on social media at
Ted Alexandro Instagram Twitter and of
course Ted Alexandro calm all right
hopper at the verse ted was taking
valuable time away from his family to do
this so let him know on social media
showing your support go watch his new
special go listen to his podcast and we
will be back tomorrow with Beth Stelling
everyone so have a good day out there
excellent
[Music]